[Music]
so another picture of you with with two
of the rolling stones this is a very
impressive
picture and yeah good god he's Richard
ISM is become a pirate yeah do an actual
pyre a pirate yeah Ronnie would randomly
asked me out to dinner and I couldn't
make it and then he said you know if you
want to come see your show feel free and
so I went to go see them at Staples and
he took me backstage brought me over to
Keith Richards and introduced me and
he's just breathing on me with his
alcoholic craze like there's every form
of alcohol coming out of his mouth and
it was amazing I was like I love this
man so much and then I introduced him to
my wife and he's like ah there's your
first mistake never get married that's
great to say in front of your wife then
his wife comes running to take a picture
with us he's like oh here she comes
madly in love great couple I love them
to death but yeah we now for obvious
reasons you're you're here promoting the
the final season of Breaking Bad and for
obvious reasons
you guys aren't releasing a clip you're
not gonna most guests in your position
would now show a preview clip of the
season but you guys have this thing
tightly locked down and I think that's
appropriate yeah but you're not going to
show a clip but you said you would do
something for us instead of showing a
clip you want to explain what that is
you know you say dinky the donkey please
my wife is so impressed that I can tie
cherry stems with my tongue and so she
ya see all the ladies scream out is so
funny
my-my wife filmed me doing it once and
she posted it on her Instagram and I got
like it went viral and she's thinks it's
so so funny that I can do it and the
reason why I started to just teach
myself how to do it is because ladies
find it impressive for some reason and
so I heard the craft of well we have
some cherries right here instead of a
Breaking Bad clip Aaron Paul is now Wow
I can't believe I can't believe this so
these are always ready and available for
you guys so far got any one here we go
so you just remove the stem good
[Applause]
that is that's a beautiful knot q that's
a sailor's knot
oh babe yeah like that people were like
okay no Breaking Bad clip but that's
fine yeah be the final episode you just
doing that this is me doing that